hey how's it going how's it going hey
house to go let's go how's it go brother
system refresh and welcome to 2015
January maybe I should check that out
ah [ __ ] just smell
I'm so sorry Bernie and mr. Crabb you
coming with me
oh it's dr. crab god dammit Aldous
murdered his children what he's not
watching someone's eating my ass oh my
ass ah what the [ __ ] are you
whoa whoa this is the greatest game ever
ah
oh Jesus Christ
he's trying to become a helicopter
rolled again
just kidding wait to get on the road
again oh god he's on this floor oh that
booty baby lap that booty big huh Oh
booty baby wait okay all the chins the
chins
oh oh oh please please gonna have the
shakers with Spears please please I have
no quarter with your beer let me have
your sneakers emoji hi
so good what the [ __ ] I can't fight it
be now get him a fight my mom ah
hey fitness job debarred oh my god
[ __ ] cute ass skeletons man one two
three strong penis nicki manaj up in
this [ __ ]
day I'm coughing just a bow wow thanks
are you [ __ ] kidding me
moving on Germany's after me now [ __ ]
take a MIDI just the regular photo pie
video right here how's it going everyone
you look beautiful
can I touch your face Hey look at that
still going strong
never mind you made a
I'm so glad we can play it out no no
here we are there we go just leave your
legs in your legs and eat your legs
[ __ ] you you know what oh and some no
that's up you need t went through the
wall here superpowers is booting
now oh a butt monster of course
ha ha ha love me - a baby
don't wake leg when you say dad you're
[ __ ] beautiful
oh it's so creepy
no you can crouch in this there it is
there's a poop coming get in the furnace
this conveniently plays furnace again
I'm innocent
I might find gosh it was a trap sorry I
feel a little sick I don't know what
happened and now you were a stone that's
how ugly you are
that's racist Jesus Christ you're ugly
what that [ __ ] that looks like his
actual skin I have to go
[ __ ] it's the best [ __ ] bridge oh god
oh god oh god I can't tell you what
happened but I can show you my clothes
do we - no no that's Annie
this blog never our eyelids delicious I
don't know I never tried one ready
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
feel like a machine
yeah baby what are you doing no no help
god damn immigrant Oh moon is really
cold I'm not a Swedish anymore with the
controller inside so cool and it says 26
on it we look the same everyone says we
look the same
yeah where am I where's Dutch I got a
mess here oh god I grave
Robinson three
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah this is not one another
white one says pressed the blue one says
abort there's two buttons yeah in
different slot okay
is just a prank
Jace's [ __ ] christ [ __ ] uncut in the
buddies and dumbest [ __ ] idea ever
[ __ ] ad right oh god it's my Friday
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off it's mine holy Sh
oh god there's an electrical cabinet
there I got a probe to me no you are
dating Serena find Arabs time she has a
dick okay I won round one there are more
rounds to be lost don't worry about it
let's do another song sooo happen in a
year because we're so close
what an amazing year huh
what side
Bres I hope you enjoyed this montage
2015 was the most intense year of my
life and I am so happy that I got to
share it with you bros and I just want
to say I can't wait for 2016 it's gonna
be the best year ever
and as always thank you for being a bro
and always being there stay awesome